the jurogan experience tell me the ufo
story
all right
um
well first i'm going to tell you about
my dad real quick my dad is
sicilian to the [ __ ] he born and raised
bronx okay grew up in the 1960s in the
bronx
always has to dress nice
you know very materialistic a man needs
a watch
a man needs shoes okay me and my brother
were in the car one time my father would
do this [ __ ] we were young he shouldn't
have but he would be like
he'd be like look at that you see that
that's a [ __ ] disgrace he'd be like
that's a man in a honda yeah
and he'd be like there's kids in that
[ __ ] car like it's like that wow 1982
jaguar xj6 black white leather
dressed to the nines you know
everybody's crazy but him [ __ ]
they're crazy [ __ ] great so
tells me in my brother's story to this
day the story is not changing he told me
he wish he never saw what he saw 1973 my
mother is pregnant with my older brother
christian
uh he's five years older than me okay so
she's pregnant with them they're outside
in yonkers there's a little grass lot
and my aunt grandmother and mother are
out there and they're screaming tommy
you got to come out here you got to come
out here so the way my father tells the
story he goes i'm watching tv what the
[ __ ] you know i don't wanna be bothered
because i go outside and he said paul
he said sitting where i could throw a
rock or shoot my gun at it
there is a [ __ ] and the way he said
flying saucer which is [ __ ] hilarious
it's a [ __ ] flying saucer and he said
it's got a blue
tint around it
little portholes but you could barely
see quiet
quiet as can be and he said they were
all and he said the time was weird the
time of night was weird it was like that
weird time where the sun's going down
you don't know he said the timing of it
was weird and he said his time
perception during it was was very
something was off with the time
and he said
he thought he said holy [ __ ] i could
[ __ ] shoot my gun at this thing but
then he goes he goes then i freaked out
because i don't know if this thing's
reading my [ __ ] mind so i went inside
because he thought that it might have
been so he went inside he looked again
he went outside they looked at it they
were stunned and he said like that it
turned into a dot in the sky
uh he said like that it turned into a
star like that and he says to this day
exactly the same thing he goes paul i
always used to think those people were
[ __ ] nuts
he was all those people i thought they
were [ __ ] hillbillies somewhere in
the midwest just trying to get attention
he goes i know what the [ __ ] i saw and
he goes and i wish i didn't see it
because i still dream about it and i
know what the [ __ ] i saw and i know it
wasn't from here that's 100 true what
year was this 1973 73. and then i
googled 1973 yonkers and many people saw
something but it was right above them
look at this man says 1973 uf's whole
incident turned life upside down wow
i'm not surprised no that thing it
probably looked just like that that one
right there that's what yeah yeah
when it's funny because when he
describes it it looks like that like in
my mind that's what he said it looked
like and that's what i always thought
about that right there but he said that
it was gone and like he said he couldn't
believe he said my mother's very like
religious so the other day we had a
party and somebody
might have actually been honest he goes
you know i've got to find out can i talk
and she goes she goes i saw that she
goes i was honest i saw that we saw that
that thing just disappeared my father
said if he had a picture in 1973 of
where it was nobody would ever had a
picture like that because i've been a
[ __ ] millionaire yeah he said nobody
it was right there he said he said you
could have maybe not thrown something
but shoot at it wow yeah man well that
thing right there is a copy by this guy
designed by perry uh the e and perry is
a three on instagram and he he recreated
that thing that's a recreation of what
bob lazar
allegedly worked on in area s4 yeah and
that's exactly how he described it he
said this thing was running on something
called element 115 element 115 is
apparently
some element that was just theoretical
until like the the early 2000s i think
it was like 2013 or something like that
they recreated in a large hadron
collider
but before in a particle collider but
before that
he was saying that these people had he
was talking about this in 1989 that
these people
who were working on this thing trying to
back engineer it they described it as
being some sort there's some sort of an
engine
that works
off of this uh element and that what it
does is it bends gravity so instead of
instead of like a rocket where fire
comes out the back and it pushes the
rocket forward right this thing bends
space and time so it bends gravity and
pushes it through yeah that's why it's
totally silent the thing is it's like it
sounds crazy but all these things that
these
pilots have seen
that they describe having no heat
signature
no visible means of propulsion they're
all moving that same way yeah exactly
how your dad described yeah and i didn't
know that the bending gravity was why it
was silent but everybody that i know
says they see one says silent yeah
there's never noise
like any sort of engine which is wild it
is pretty wild but i mean you know
everybody's like we're seeing [ __ ] but
if one person saw it if they only came
down for like a half hour an hour
you know few people saw it then it took
off it never came back again those
people would be confused like your dad
probably for the rest of their lives
just thinking about it
yeah and he's
he's so detailed every single time and
he says he goes he goes what i don't
like about seeing it was i knew that i
was seeing something that was just
unexplained and not from here and it's
and i know it's out there
and he's just [ __ ] up by it you know i
would imagine
what do you think they're doing
making sure we don't blow ourselves up
probably
when every civilization i i think
there's probably a bunch of different
kinds of life forms in space right like
millions of different kinds but i think
they must know that we operate
off of
biological needs like we have a
biological need to procreate a
biological need to protect our our
village and to protect our stuff and so
we're warring still okay yet we're
moving this technological age of
sophistication where we have nuclear
bombs and video that travels on your
phone to the other side of the world in
a half a second all the wild [ __ ] that
we can do now that makes it very complex
for us to manage both our primate
instincts and the responsibility of
having incredible power
so they're probably like just let's just
[ __ ] keep an eye on these [ __ ]
why why would they care because they
don't want us to blow ourselves up think
about how many billions of years it took
for us to become what we are right you
go from the single-celled organism right
to what a human being is now that is a
long road to for us to just knock the
dominoes over
because some guy has a hard-on right
that's putin right yeah yeah like if
putin is just like [ __ ] you
and he just [ __ ] nukes ukraine and
then we nuke him and then china nukes us
and yeah you know that kind of [ __ ] is a
real possibility and i if i was an alien
i was like look they're so close to
getting it right they're so close to
getting it together yeah that that could
be
yeah dude i don't know i tell you what
if i saw it it would [ __ ] me up what do
you think it is what do you think
they're doing if that's real let's just
assume that this isn't just a mass
hallucination yeah what do you what do
you think it is
uh
i think they're just curious man i think
they're just watching and i think i
don't know i i would say i don't know
that they care i wouldn't think that
they would care but i think they're just
watching us but what if this i always
thought about this what if they created
us
like wear their ant farm yeah and i
thought of that too you know like like
one of them like
[ __ ] something down and just started
something yeah you know what if they
took like a chimpanzee or they took
something that was here first
[ __ ] it and was like let's look at
this thing grow and then they're just
looking and they're showing up and
they're that's one of the things bob
lazar said he said
yeah he said that one of their um
there's there was a bunch of briefings
that they had and a bunch of documents
in one of the documents they talked
about how human beings are some sort of
a product of accelerated evolution